this episode of the pain game podcast is
sponsored by raid shadow legends this is
my champion gaelic a handsome man like
myself masculine but also comfortable
with his feminine side special moves
include the cross slash we've also got
this
lovely lady right here her skills
include the double shot an array of
arrows she squirts all those arrows all
over you so i hear you asking brian
we've heard a lot about raid everyone's
done a raid i'd read at this point
what's new well i'm glad you asked this
month raid just introduced a huge new
doom tower update there are two big new
bosses to take on along with new enemy
balance on tower floors and new secret
rooms to discover god only knows what
goes on inside those rooms have a look
but knock just to be clear because you
never know you might be interrupting
something and if that's not enough this
whole month is packed with awesome
events and tournaments this is amazing
for new players if there's ever a time
to start playing raid shadow legends
it's now because you don't want to miss
this if you want an even bigger head
start all you have to do is click the
link in the description below or scan
the qr code which is right here new
players will get an epic hero known as
chonaroo and with that you'll get 200k
silver one xp boost and one energy
refill you will get an ancient shard
which means you can summon a champion as
soon as you're in the game look at this
champion you'll get for free can you
believe that you will also get extra
rewards here in your inbox for the next
30 days only it's that easy just click
the link in the description and i'll see
you in the game but for now enjoy the
podcast
[Music]
at one time i was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence and
i'm scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make a comeback
[Music]
this was designed for me to do what
makes us who we are
i'm so far ahead of this game
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
i have always been a fighter there's
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a month like that
to me i was born to do this
nobody can get close i'm the best
fighter in the world i'm the most brutal
and
efficient ever been
welcome back to the number one fight
podcast
uh it's the pain game it's my name oh
that's what it's called the pain game
podcast cool yeah will i be in pain by
the end of it uh well we want to watch
there's a bit of a different one because
obviously uh i haven't seen logan
uh since the mayweather
uh fight properly to sit down and talk
about it obviously i've seen you when
you interviewed ksi here but we also got
to catch up a bit about jake a bit about
what's happening and fighting uh we're
gonna watch logan's fight with floyd
mayweather and get some reactions of
what you were thinking about as you were
in there with floyd i don't usually get
asked one of my mates when it's like the
hip floyd well i i've i've not watched
the fight back i have not watched the
fight back not a complete round i've
seen highlights i've been waiting to
watch it with my coach milton but we
just haven't been able to link i'm a bit
more of a boxing brain than milton to be
honest yeah i think i could give you
better insight i'm joking i'm joking no
don't hit me we got him we got him
falling asleep on the on the vlog yeah
he's always sleeping no but um he did a
really good uh breakdown of his style
with a guy from the north of england
tony jeffries olympic boxer and he
explained exactly a lot of the benefits
of fighting with your hands down and and
the reasons behind that 100 fascinating
he really came across well in that yeah
i'm glad we're doing this bro yeah you
asked me to do it last time i was like
you know i'm waiting for milan you asked
me today
let's do it because if not now then
never there you go bro well you haven't
uploaded to the main channel since the
fight yeah your last video is my final
words to
floyd those are yeah those three might
have been my final words
all right we're gonna watch a little bit
of the jake highlights first because you
are literally ringside with your phone
now screaming at woodley how did you see
this fight when you were watching it
live i was screaming a lot i i also was
like [__] with tyrion i could tell
yeah i said some [__] up [__] bro
i screamed at him i said i said tyron
you were the worst guest on impulsive
fact jake said that was the one thing he
heard me say
of all the things i said you really were
in his head a little bit as well but
obviously i i can't um believe how how
much tyron sucks i mean you say that but
he did catch jake with this shot right
here yeah what was that like for you in
that moment okay oh so there's you in
the bottom corner i was under
jake his butt was this close to my face
dude i was under him and
it was scary because i couldn't really
see the shot it was right you know he
was jake was blocking me and he like
fell and i was like oh [__] is this is
this it like is this the end of jake
paul
because when he goes to fight that's
what i'm look that's what i'm concerned
about i'm like what like everyone wants
them to fall like are they gonna see it
tonight is this it is this happening now
that's why people are buying a lot of
these pay-per-views yeah they want him
to lose yeah it was horrifying
that sucks
he recovered well though
he's tough as [__] bro the kid's i mean
his head is his head is bigger than you
he's got a big head for a guy smaller
than me yeah yeah yeah
okay tyron couldn't close the show and
jake immediately showed he was still
with it and he was enjoying it
regardless yeah so so so this is why
they call him the frozen one woodley
tyrone the frozen one because he froze
he i mean he had him this was an
interesting moment yeah where he's
trying to close the show
and jake seems to land a good shot on
him here and then he falls into him now
a lot of people said you did that to
floyd but you didn't this was a genuine
falling into the guy yeah and
i don't think jake got a lot of praise
for that shot right there right tyrone
got wobbled watch his feet this is a
wobble
that was a wobble yeah and he fell and
jnj caught him i didn't i did not get
wobbled with floyd exactly tyron the
frozen one woodley he had it all and he
blew it you know what boxing is bro it's
acting so when you get hit with a good
shot you pretend like it's not and
woodley bought jake's acting he stuck
his tongue out after he hit him with a
hard shot like it was nothing the output
of jake was far
more impressive than woodley's woodley
was
so slow to get going but most of his
fights are like that yeah i thought
that's why i would lose to be honest
when i did my breakdown i said he just
doesn't throw enough punches to trans uh
translate from an mma fighter
because you can't just look for that one
big shot when you haven't got the four
ounce gloves on you gotta really put
some work in yeah to earn the win
and you know what i realize about
woodley i do have to give him credit
he's he's tough as [__] dude oh yeah
he's tough i think jay gave him respect
in the footwork jake was on his bike a
lot yeah and he was he was moving a bit
more like you
actually um in terms of you know
circling away from the power shot and
trying to
be a smart fighter yeah instead of just
a destroyer which is what he'd been in
every fight but before now it's so
interesting to see
from this angle you know because i was
ringside and i haven't watched his fight
definitely looks it looks
it looks way more intense here to be
honest yeah by the way bro
split decision my [__]
ass it actually disgusts me that boxing
is in a state where uh three different
judges have three different opinions
watching the same [__] fight
the those are the experts no it was
amazing
that far off no but
there's something about this that just
doesn't add up because
we i had two pro boxers watching uh the
stream with us and an mma expert and
everyone in the room was torn between
you know one or two rounds for woodley
maybe if you're being generous three
yeah not one of us said that this was
even a close fight when we had split
decision i thought there's some [__]
going on here this doesn't make sense
jake said it a long time ago
he it kind of got a little backlash he
said boxing's rigged
i don't know like if it is or if it
isn't but not all boxing but surely a
lot of it there's definitely some bts
[__] going on that that's definitely not
cool because it ruins the magic of the
sport i want to give credit to showtime
actually they made a a
a amazing video where you can see you
everything you're saying in the fight
you want to see some of that yeah this
is one of the best you know in-fight
edits i've ever watched to be honest
really it's it's stunning they're
keeping the like the good stuff bro oh
this is where you really see the impact
that you're having on the fight actually
because it comes to you a lot what was
it like being back home in cleveland for
you guys the coolest thing ever one of
one of the most special weekends of my
life dude coming out to uh machine gun
kelly it is surreal dude you my brother
sold out an arena
in his hometown fantastic
what
are you fighting
yeah he was reacting to everything that
he did yeah the fans the fans were
working well fainter i mean
i had
that combination was beautiful as well
that was the first one i saw him decide
to unload
i felt like you were putting the full
stop on every combo that when you were
get when you were saying all that it was
like
when you hear someone celebrating your
wins that much at ringside it can only
help you in there that's why too and
he's he's
25.
tyron you lost me 20.
he literally did lose you two 20k
because you bet on him for that fight
after that he swore he was gonna win
against uzman won it yeah and i didn't
and i i did no research on guzman i've
never heard of him
loved everyone
woodley since
only six punches in the first round six
punches in the first round by one that's
ridiculous we got through the first
round he's done now now we're ready to
go i like bj flores he really seems to
be a good influencer yeah he really is
[Applause]
the fact that you're still performing
your brothers
i was talking to the score the
scorekeeper next to me uh after the
round of like who'd you give that one to
he goes you know i can't focus if you're
i'm like i'm like shut up bro
that wasn't even close
this has never happened in boxing surely
and and jake basically answered all the
doubters in in one round he is for real
he is yeah and this is not going to be
no woodley walk over as people some
people were suggested yeah no because i
was tweeting out jake's going to win i
did a whole breakdown real quick one
minute why this is why jake's going to
win and i was getting people tweeting me
like how could anyone
think jake paul could beat a profile you
you would you would have to be a [__]
to think tyron was going to win that
fight i'm not i'm not kidding there's
there wasn't a [__] ounce of a chance
there just wasn't um and the great thing
about this is you know i do think jake
learned a lot in going that eight rounds
because you've had long fights before
you've had to dig deep you you know
where you have to go to do that yeah but
when you've got the power that jake has
in the in the opponents that jake's had
he's never really had to do that so i
think this can only help them really
yeah i i you know it's so funny everyone
has an opinion about the fight game but
unless you know the fight game
it's all good opinions are cool and
stuff but bro tyron
it was over before he walked in the ring
unfortunately for him his age his
inability to actually box
jake's hunger
it's a wrap i felt like around
jake paul
it's not right in the air of the skull
guys no no no no i i wish they kept that
in dude so that right to the body left
hand upstairs has been the money combo
for paul yeah
[Applause]
it's wild and it's saying family members
just root for the downfall of the other
guys so badly yeah i've seen the most
kind-hearted people just turn into cruel
bastards when they've got a family
member in there yep i've seen you
cracking onto one of the ring girls any
joy oh bro yeah
yeah that went that went a little viral
yeah jake is super keen on uh julia huh
they're in love dude bro i see it on
your podcast when he was like i'll put a
[__] house on a ring he did you know
he did yeah they're in love it's it's
disgusting
oh this is the big shot right here
look i'm i was under him yeah
oh [__]
that did feel like the moment when we
were watching it or you're like oh [__]
it did i mean it was it was the one
moment that he had a shot and he [__]
blew it yeah but that job in return and
that right hand a jab is a good reset oh
100 flush jab is a [__] fantastic
reset yeah and and he got him yeah that
that alone could have just been enough
to get tyron to go okay he's still
dangerous yep yep because you know also
tyron's made that mistake before oh yeah
he's wobbled someone and he and he goes
for a kill shot and he got [__] in
that last fight he was fighting like a
crazy bastard before in his final ufc
fight and he hurt the guy but the other
guy just dug deep and got him out of
there yeah i don't think he wants to get
hit no no that's the problem he's not
willing to risk enough
to get the win whereas jake is in my
opinion but i think jake newey was out
boxing him so that he didn't have to
risk yeah yeah so the bonus is on the
guy who's getting pissed up isn't it and
that's been tyron's problem
against colby you know uzman he knows he
has to risk getting knocked out but he
isn't willing to go there
and that's a mental thing i think at
that age that he's at he's just not
willing to
sacrifice yeah that left hook is a solid
left hook from jake's
look at this guy look at this dude's
[__] eyes right now that's a crazy
person that's a wild man dude tyron this
is where tyra needs to get that respect
i'm a fighter too i'm [__] compelled
i love it
that's the only thing i was worried
about was this gas hunt
but i i i was i'm not worried i just
wanted to see yeah you know because i
see him conditioning and training and
[__] and i guess it's it's that um not
knowing isn't it like first time in a
fight where there's another guy who is a
legit world champion chasing you down
can you keep that pace up and one of the
little mistakes i think he made is his
footwork like early on he was really on
his bike like almost doing a little too
much yep
[Applause]
if your woman's screaming that out
that's a that's a good woman right hell
yeah yeah hell yeah the rest of your
life yeah julia's the best especially
for jake
yeah they seem a good team he's playing
the um the matador yeah the matador
the ball lost yeah that's a wrap [__]
out of here bro
okay let's let's go on to your fight bro
because this is one i've been wanting to
watch with you
since the day it happened i'm i've been
wanting to watch it since the day it
happened i've never see i've never seen
this in full
production like this
here he comes bro this this walkout was
everything to me i'm even getting
goosebumps just thinking about it now it
makes me emotional a little bit
um
oh man it's like making me emotional i
love the road by the way bro thank you
bro yeah uh i i i
a
amazing i love the soundtrack from now
on from the greatest showman uh a story
that rings true and i can relate to in
my life and by the way
one of the greatest musicals ever
i love this song i love what i meant it
was playing in the background you know
it's not like a fight walk out song it's
not a hip-hop song it's a [__] it's a
musical it's about what it means to use
exactly and bro every time i listen to
this song
it's like it's anthemic it's melodic
there's there's cheers there's chances
of screams there's there's
there's people learning from their
mistakes and believing in what they can
do and i'm walking out there and in
front of my friends my family with um my
lucky charm around my neck you know
against the greatest fighter of all time
like everything about this is just
impossible yeah and and the fact that
it's happening is like you see me
smiling and [__] this is nuts that made
me feel great watching you guys thank
you that you were smiling i thought this
is not the logan we've seen before he's
enjoying this and that's what matters it
was the mistake i made my first two
fights with chaos i wasn't having fun
yeah but when i'm having fun i i i won't
be be if i'm smiling i'm laughing that
gave me all the faith and all the
confidence i was like okay he's feeling
good that's all we want just 100 me but
i'm a [__] goofball but i'm also a
badass and when i live in that space and
i can just like stay grounded and talk
to my manager have some fun you see me
walking around the ring just like
talking to leonard floyd's guy like
yeah this that the guy with the mic i
was just having conversations and
and going back to the showman on the
podcast we did here where you're about
to fight uh jj the second time you said
the goal is to be the best showman
in in the game yeah like the rock for
example yeah and when you're going out
i'm like [__] me
this [__] is happening yeah it's
materializing yeah this is all part of
it it's crazy it was you know my whole
life my goal was to be the biggest
entertainer in the world and this night
i definitely was oh yeah you were the
talk of the whole entire game fight game
entertainment game everything it's here
he is it's great it's it's crazy to see
your goals manifest in a way that
like like yo that's that's [__] floyd
mayweather dude
what the [__] happened
yo
i was sitting watching like i remember
when they first announced this and then
it's like but to see it
it's like whoa what the [__] is he doing
now bro it's why at
i don't want anyone to tell me
anything's impossible like shut up
yeah well it must feel that that side of
it must have felt satisfying just to get
floyd in the ring with you
it proves you are the [__] winner
yeah yeah everyone knew it before the
fight started i had already won no
matter what happened i had already won
you're in the corner now is where the
real event begins because you've now got
to go out and just
survive at the very least you don't want
to you want to do well you want to win
but you know there was no official
winner and you knew if you just looked
good decent even you've won yeah are you
having any of those fears of or what if
this guy really hurts me what's going
through your head about a month before
the fight
jake came over to my house it was like
midnight
like bro can i ask you something
he goes yeah i was like if you were
fighting floyd mayweather like
what would you
do because i i like candidly bro i'm
having
major major like
fears about potentially getting knocked
out or or strung out on the canvas and
you know being memed for the rest of my
life and it's it's it's it's a scary
thought how can you not think that
the greatest fighter ever yeah and and
you know why i got a call that day from
someone who watched him spar and i'm
hoping you know he's like still old or
old and it doesn't doesn't move as fast
and this this dude very honestly he's
like yo
floyd floyd
made three different people quit and
bleed today in sparring for 13 hard
rounds
this was a month out
and i was like holy [__]
that sucks
like i don't know fear was the right
word but for the first time i had i had
hesitation oh yeah about about my
absolutely normal for sure it's normal
but i'm not like a normal guy and it was
unknown
normal from abnormal you're freaking out
for the first time yeah but by the time
by the time fight night came around you
you what did you expect when you asked
him for that advice what did he say did
you do the breathing
no
no what did he say i forget
but it helped it helped more than i was
just like telling someone just to admit
that shows that that was the important
thing bingo to one person bro and not
anyone right because i gotta i gotta
convince you know my boy kevin i gotta
go convince my coach that i'm i can
[__] win but like my brother i was
like bro who does the same fight yeah
it's like yeah this is [__] floyd
mayweather dude
yeah just to get that off your chest is
healthy it helps process that i always
like to be open about how i'm feeling
well you looked in amazing shape bro so
you must have been doing all of the work
yeah i i really was bro my conditioning
is [__] it's good i i thought you
really carried yourself so well into the
later rounds even though obviously
earlier if uh if the fight went 10 or 12
rounds i i think i'd knock him out i say
that in full [__] conviction bro i
saw him breathing heavy for the first
time that eighth round and it was
because i had been leaning on him i'm 30
pounds heavier bro like no matter how
you cut it me leaning on you a guy that
size is gonna get him tired i don't care
how good he is the thing is true boxing
heads they'll back flight of the hill
and they'll say you know skills yadda
yadda
but but if they really look
in the reality of what they know to be
true in boxing every
boxing guy knows when you've got a big
guy leaning on you the longer the fight
goes the more that takes its toll and
the more you'll end up hurting him i was
coming alive too and you're getting a
second win but that's your engagement he
can't recover like you can age and
that's that's what we trained for
bro we spar for 12 rounds by the 12th
round i'm throwing the most hundreds
probably probably 120 punches in round
in in sparring like my my condition my
conditioning is good i had a little lull
in the fourth round and then second one
came back that's the only thing with
boxing as a spot is you have to have
those like even anthony joshua will take
multiple rounds off because he's a big
guy and that's a [__] long time to
throw punches even just saying that me
mayweather versus paul and you guys in
the ring that was a trip oh i'm getting
goosebumps this is this is crazy bro
so this first round
i i wanted to gauge his reaction and see
how quick he really was whether it was
me faking or true which i realized very
soon i'm fast twitch as [__] bro i'm
quick i'm the fastest man on the planet
i've said it before i'll say it again
i'll never prove it but i'll continue to
say it i love it and uh yeah especially
with my my fakes and a lot of my like
jabs are snappy like watch you see me
you see me start to up my my my um my
faints
and he's biting he bites at every single
one you can see that little [__] that
little toe in his direction was enough
to get him jumping yep and he's like
come on he's not even biting a little
bit he's across the ring by the time you
[__] move a lot yeah and so and so
you can see me like making faces at him
i'm like oh this is the goat yeah yeah
every single thing i get like a little
a huge reaction and i mean credit to
floyd he could probably do that all day
because he is you know a legend and all
of that but just just to even get that
level of respect out of him
should prove something look at this
punch
right there when i dodged that punch and
i saw him actually put some effort
behind it and i and i s i saw it and i
dodged it i went holy [__] this guy
he's not the floor he used to be a
hundred percent
yeah he got a tongue out with him
straight after that okay i prove
something yeah immediately proved
something look at that yeah bro i hit
him with a jab he went flying across
here he reacted there like what are you
doing he does a really good job with me
anyways
of of uh keeping keeping distance
between us oh absolutely
you know i and that's why you know i
faint and he steps two feet back and
he's away from me i can't get him
you know every time your toe moves floyd
is aware of it yeah he's not there
there's nothing going to surprise him
but but as you get tired
even floyd got surprised a few times
yeah
he's he's really good at keeping
distance dude like it's it's it's
it's scary how good he is at it you have
a great balance between strength speed
and stamina that's it you're an
all-rounder you know what i mean you
could probably pick most things up so i
think it says a lot that you've you've
got in there with him and managed to
apply yourself for long enough where you
could really
show
a respectable open for a guy who isn't
officially a boxer by comparison to
floyd floyd mayweather guaranteed that
he was going to knock me out yeah and he
couldn't you didn't even get [__]
close bro in fact you got smacked up
like no i busted his eardrum it's down
low [__] no one knows about it but my
boy caught it his uh uh doctor checking
out his ear and admitted to his ear
being busted yeah you've got very so
right here bro i hit him with a right
right there
and i s i felt him drop a little bit and
jake goes he's hurt so i said [__] it
this is it i yeah his head goes down
immediately a little too far it wasn't a
it wasn't just a roll it was a little
bit of like
okay i got tagged well his head's near
his [__] angle when he actually goes
down initially because he meant that he
went to roll yeah
but he got a shot he hit with a good
shot
so he went a little lower than he showed
up i was like i think i got him and i
heard jake go he's hard
and i just unloaded the sloppiest
barrage of boxing punches
you'll ever see
i know the boxing uh you know experts
have highlighted bro i panicked in my
mind i just like wobbled one of the
greatest fighters of all time i'm like
i'm going to do whatever the [__] it
takes to kill this you did what a lot of
people would have done which is exactly
why in our podcast beforehand i remember
saying to you
don't go after him in the first round i
know i remember saying over and over
don't don't no but look how many people
have been in there with him where they
think they've got him hit of course
you're going to pull the trigger and to
be fair you put some [__] power into
it yeah all these shots hurt yeah you
know it's not it's not like you know i
can feel this [__] i slipped one
uppercut right there and
and and do you know what it is right
even just to fit to physically watch a
man
bully floyd the way you did then yeah
floyd was defending very well but the
point is is he had to cover the [__] up
and respect you at that point because
you were the you were the hammer and he
was the nail and he had to just take
that for a second and i know it's great
from him but credit to you he came in
you pushed him into that [__] corner
and went after him in my opinion that's
where floyd lost
it because i'm gonna be honest with you
like no winner right and and he probably
won more rounds than me but like
with with that being said
i i'm the winner of this fight there's
no other way to cut it i won when i
walked in the ring with floyd and the
fact that he could knock me out and he's
on my highlight reel and i sent him into
retirement like
i think it happened
because of that barrage in the first
round i i think he he had to respect me
like i'm willing i'm willing to put it
all on the line yeah he knows that now
and this is the thing
if floyd wasn't respecting you he
wouldn't have been maintaining the eye
contact and the body language he does in
the corner this is for your benefit it's
not for anyone else's he's
psychologically trying to tell you i'm
not bothered by that and the fact that
he's feeling the need to do that to even
play the game that's respect in some way
because look at him here
he's watching me constantly watching
just looking at me he wants to see how
hard you're breathing
he's he he's he's analyzing you the
whole time
if this is not a man who could just get
rid of you any time he wanted as many
claimed
and jake doing exactly as you did in
giving everything from the sideline
he's made the second round
because that's an achievement in their
eyes and that's the thing the the
english commentary um shout out to vidal
actually because vidal was on our
commentary but an american commentary as
well whenever youtube has boxed they
always seem to take like
a level of snobbery towards you guys oh
he's made the second round it was
actually annoying i got a lot of
comments from um people that the
announcers were uh uh
overwhelmingly biased in a way that it
actually
it wasn't cool yeah it could
showtime or floyd's guys
you have to respect boxing as a sport
and like it's floyd mayweather he's
royalty and i get it but like at what
point you know like respect respect the
match and that you're watching and not
your preconceived notions and and don't
speak on that speak on what's taking
place but boxers will pick and choose
because those same people
will go i respect anyone who gets in the
ring well
then act like it you know what i mean
he's trying to um get a bit closer to
you this year yeah yeah so now so now he
now he's testing me a little bit you
know
and uh i and i felt that but it's it's
it's good he he levels up as the fight
goes on yeah any any he did that to
connor very well yeah very well and he
tried he tried to do it with me
you'll see in round uh i think it's the
end i think it's it's either the end of
three or four he covers up he changes
his style but you know now he's way more
aggressive than he was even the first
first round by the probably like 20 25
and that's the thing is that that's kind
of why i was saying don't use a lot of
energy early because he he is great at
that
to be honest with you though bro like i
i'm not going to run out of energy like
it happened my very first fight
adrenaline dump but my conditioning is
now you can say you're good here
but you're a big guy yeah
you just have to power a much bigger
machine than he does yeah i think your
uh your footwork and your job by the way
it's really come on leaps and bounds
thank you bro honestly yeah i had eight
months to prepare for this you know
i hope i get a little better anyways
yeah no it's definitely coming on and uh
my coach who i was telling you about uh
lauren suspect is uh
olympic team boxer um he thinks you're
probably the most naturally gifted of
all the boxers arguably well you and
jake you put up there but
your style is a really hard one to
defeat and i think we haven't really
seen how hard you ought to be because
you immediately went to floyd mayweather
yeah after ksi yeah so a lot of the
teachings you've had like if you'd
fought in austin mcbroom for example i
think then people would get a more of an
appreciation for the amount that you've
improved because it's hard to say
because you've gone up there it's fun
it's [__] mayweather
yeah boxing puts me in like a
i get combative and excited and like my
arrogance comes out a little bit bro but
i truthfully believe i i will not be
beat
after this fight um surviving and even
thriving against floyd mayweather what
that does for you mentally is especially
in boxing it is your head movement was
very impressive yeah thank you i didn't
even i didn't get to show it bro this
was this was a c minus fight for me this
wasn't because because it was floyd like
i felt good on that day but he's so
[__] good bro it's hard for me to
look good exactly exactly but that's
what i'm taking into account when i'm
watching this is this is floyd
mayweather and the fact that you're able
to evade some of his strikes with the
little just a tiny little flick of the
head it says a lot like i say if it was
austin mcbroom in there or one of these
other guys
then people be like wow look at how good
logan's gotten they'd i think you got
more credit if the competition hadn't
have just gone up by
such a huge jump obviously so look this
is where his style starts to shift he
brings his hands up and now he's walking
in to see what i do
and uh this style is called pressure
fighting
and he's not really fighting right now
he's more just putting on the pressure
and then in round four he starts
fighting from the hands up from the
guard i think conor accused this of like
oh he's fighting like a mexican now
that's what he would say
yeah yeah it's yeah it's a it's a it's a
pressure cooker you know he's a [__]
buzz saw when he would hit me in the
stomach bro i whisper in his ear i go
[__] i do sit up you know i think
there's a secret ingredient that you
guys have that they aren't really
factoring in when they fight you which
is yeah you might not have the
experience in boxing but you guys are
are winners at multiple different
aspects of your life
and that was a lovely cup by the way he
smiled nice little snuck that one in
there boom he popped his head up and you
see him he has to appreciate it you
gotta acknowledge probably i'm a big guy
bro i don't hate light exactly people
think boxers are superhuman and that
sort of stuff but not all boxers are
born winners some of these guys are born
to be journey men and and they haven't
got the
the mental capacity to to to get their
heads on what it takes to get at the top
of any any industry whereas
because you guys have done that that was
a lovely slip because you guys have done
that i think
that's the x factor of why you're able
to do well in these kind of situations
because
you know what it takes to win at
different things at the highest levels
we've done it dude success is a is a
it's a character trait yeah and we have
it and that's the thing i think people
can't quite because with me hanging out
with other boxers and i come out with
things and they go oh yeah and i realize
like just because i'm not a pro fighter
doesn't mean i can't
give advice in winning yeah
damn bro he kept hugging me and [__]
yeah no i'm just kidding okay i kept
hugging him well because i love him
that's why
that was a good shot by floyd yeah that
was the first good shot i think really
of the fight from him though okay so
yeah and see now he's now he's thrown
from the guard now and he's got a sick
hook from the guard it's it's it's a
it's a counter punch and the the
commentary are already calling the the
mcgregor fight and saying you know
logan's gonna slow down and floyd's
going to take him apart but that wasn't
in the script
this is round four where you said you
were struggling quite
so so
this round four was by far the hardest
round
for me i was starting to get tired you
can see me leaning over there in the
corner i even told my coaches they said
how you feeling i said you know i'm
tired he said no you're not i was like
okay
yeah that's the hook from the guard that
you were on about yeah or such oh this
is where floyd thinks he can get you out
of there
this is where he tried to turn on those
jets yeah i remember being disappointed
i remember i really do um because he he
he was and is so good
that it's it he made it very hard for me
to be as good as i am and that's the
thing is like i said again against the
boxer who had been training the same
length of time as you the angles that
you like to pick the footwork the the
accuracy which you can use sometimes you
know you hit him with a decent shot
there that would have shown so much more
he bites in these fakes
because the the target's [__] tiny
yeah compared to how big you are you got
a tiny head too yeah absolutely it's got
a good chin for a small guy yeah he
really does he really does oh
that was i remember there was one jet i
don't know if this was it this is the
job where you had this guy looking at
the lights yep was it this one this must
be it looks like it from the hip
there you go i think there was another
one that was a good that was a good shot
though
i took i'm gonna be honest with you i
took i took a bit of a page out of ksi's
book in this fight yeah make it rough
yeah yeah bro i was like [__] it this
dude's
clearly better than me
[__] it i'm gonna hold him i'm gonna
grab him and i'm a swing for the fences
and that's gotta be applauded you know
you took different a different attitude
[__] starched me there bro that was
his his two straight two
zinc yeah that was a good shot but you
this is the thing it was it was it's
good to watch
feeling it is nothing
did that feel nothing nothing no there
was
one
face shot and one body shot that i was
like
ah okay because he he has not been a
knockout puncher obviously but you know
we wonder at this age in his life what
is he got in the tongue for a guy who's
big as you yeah you took the punch as
well ultimately that's the only thing
anyone can say you must have done a lot
of rounds and sparring and 12 yeah 12
rounds for 12 13 rounds every time bro
right here i'm [__] pissed they were
not on a cleaner angle he misses whip oh
that's such a good shot bro i licked my
glove and spanked his ass dude
i went
and smacked his ass
the fact that you slip floyd as good as
you did as big as you are i couldn't
believe more people didn't make a big
deal about that that was unbelievable
man
look at you
[__] slip and float me with those
punches
200 pounds he missed you completely yeah
andy yeah again with the job my reflexes
are pretty sharp for sure you know what
it is right i know there's a lot of uh
chat about tommy fury fighting jake paul
yeah i think you do go really well
against tommy fury i
i mean look i can talk my [__] all i
want i don't really give a [__] anymore
like i just don't think he'd hit you a
lot i i think that would be a real
problem for him right let me let me tell
you let me tell you this bro the dude
tommy fury uh sparred or uh
beat yeah the little guy bro
i have been drinking
for 45 days straight after the floyd
fight i come back to puerto rico and i'm
like
i i'll spar today first time since floyd
i sparred the kid tommy fought
he didn't make it out of the first round
okay in sparring
with head gear on and 16 ounce gloves
yeah tommy could have finished him in
four rounds with pounds get the [__] out
bro it's not even there are levels to
this [__] bro
his last name being fury is deluding
people into thinking what they're saying
in comparison to you and jake they're
automatically thinking oh fury will win
just because he's a fury
people think he's gonna win oh a lot of
people think he is the real boxer and
that jake and logan paul are the pretend
boxers well i was watching his fight
literally like
it was very clear he's still an
amateur he is an amateur right like you
mentioned to yourself
i am like athletically and genetically
gifted and built for primal combat
um and so is he
but he lacks that
i don't think he's got coordination
there's something that he lacks i feel
like the reason he gets clipped a lot is
because when he throws he leaves himself
wide open he's i don't i've never seen
his fights but
from what i saw
i mean you've seen him
fight that sparring part now that's
enough really i mean you've seen what
he's like i knew in the first round i
was like this is not there's levels to
the [__] bro and he's just not on mine
because it looks like he's gonna fight
jake next by the looks of it he's gonna
get [__] murdered absolutely murdered
and i like again anyone who thinks
otherwise is
yeah whatever
and another slip from logan paul and
another
and floyd's chasing but he's not hitting
much here he thinks he he's smiling a
lot i think he thought he had you at
that point he thought you were on the
way out i think he was having fun bro
because yo every time every time he he
he'd get me a little bit i'd swing back
look at me this is it bro fourth round
i'm like here we go
there comes a moment in every fight ooh
this is the shot ready eardrum
good douche i like that
that is it
mate
you punched me
right in the [__] head i still have
to put that clip on the impulsive uh
that's got to go on yeah it's a good
shot
got a thick skull dude oh you took it
well man i have a i fall i fall in the
one percentile as far as the cranium
density who hits harder ksi or floyd
mayweather for sure
for sure not even a competition bro
he clean shots i was like yeah like cool
like cool good good job
ksi i'm like yo keep me my [__] face
away from those hands you were
definitely
you were more um aggressive against
floyd you were more on your bike even
against uh jj i would say
oh yeah that was a different version
sure quite a long time ago you're over
the halfway mark yeah and i was
surprised that he didn't keep up the
pressure
style for a long period of time like he
kept it up a little bit during this
round and even the next round at six and
then he stopped i feel like there's a
massive drop off in energy from floyd
right now he's a master of getting the
most out of very little
so his steps alone
have changed completely bro that
combo right there that one two
it was the first like
normal combo that i've thrown in this
fight
i just didn't throw straight straight
punches you know yeah which i'm sure was
part of the game plan given the reach
that you've got but i guess
landing on him though is tricky he's hot
he's all over the place his head
with a nice hook here yeah this on the
left hook again and it's that from the
god it's he's old manning you in that
way he's he's
because he i've had that before when
you're in the ring with an older guy and
you know he's got those old tricks where
yep yep the minute you fling she knows
exactly when to detonate and everyone's
on their feet thinking you're about to
go down or whatever i don't know but
you're composed working hard lovely slip
keeping a hold of them yeah this is
where it gets sloppy sorry all admit you
got to fighting floyd mayweather is hard
absolutely you got to keep going it's
hard to do yeah you got your nice that
cut there yeah yeah
this is where i got the wall though
gotta rely on my chin a little bit i
definitely took this round off i think
he did as well though a little bit yeah
but he definitely that like his output
was higher but he for sure isn't having
the same intensity yeah
the commentators have given you some
credit saying you know at this point
they'd expect you to be um like a
lunatic just falling all over the
exhaustion but you actually have kept it
together you've stayed composed and i i
felt good for you knowing that you were
finally getting you know the right kind
of respect because it was clear that
there was not going to be a conor
mcgregor level of breaking you down and
all of that he he just couldn't i think
by this round he knew it wasn't going to
happen for him
3-2 jake says logan's up
maybe not i don't know he's a little
biased it was really cool to see floyd
work the body
as much as he did because as a newer
fighter newer fighters don't often
focus on bodywork
you know it was really cool to see an
expert in the cut doing it to me he's
trying to zap you
for sure
um and chop you down but um you do
setups it's all good i do sit upstairs
that's fine a lot of them too so so many
of them what kind of miles are you
running for a fight like this regularly
uh
or was that not between four and six a
lot of running yeah a lot of running
yeah three times a week three times a
year
nice get out there lovely you're doing a
lot of things right here bro you know i
mean i know you're giving yourself a
critique when you watch it back but
yeah you know your instincts kicked in
yeah so this is also where i started to
come alive more
yeah and and and get some energy yes in
the commentators saying you're doing
yourself proud yeah so that oh that was
a nice little job that you snuck in
there yeah it's again it's what we
talked about right it's a reset mm-hmm
it's a recent and bro even if you're
hitting gloves it's still it's still
something it gets it gets them thinking
makes them afraid to throw you're
getting through here yeah and so maybe
maybe this is i'm watching it back now
maybe this is why he's he dropped his
hands after this round because
he found it to be less effective as as i
had more energy and he definitely was
losing his
even for floyd keeping your arms up for
that length of time and throwing all
those punches it does it is going to
tire him out as well that's the the the
commentator is turning on him a little
bit right well i'm sick in the comments
maybe floyd should have got him out of
here by now so you know you should have
bro i'm a [__] youtuber bro you're
the greatest fighter of all time second
pro fight after one loss officially
50 wins for him i have no wins like i
was the tomato can you should have
starched me and you didn't yeah i love
it and that was the thing for me that
that's why i made that video right there
logan paul the real winner against floyd
mayweather oh yeah yeah yeah i
capitalized on that vidal's voice in
here we can hear saying the weight
difference
clearly uh you know more of a problem
for floyd than it was thought to have
been yeah see i didn't think it was
gonna be because when i heard about
sparring sessions they were all guys my
height and size you know and and he
[__] them up dude with again 16 ounce
gloves and head guards on like have you
thought about another fight i know
you're partying right now so i have now
not only my i mean look i'm partying
because i'm
doing something um i know who my next
opponent is okay is he a fighter or an
influencer fighter
okay can are you allowed to say no no
okay
can i ask who who
you can say no
is it
alice in silver no okay cool yeah
he just knocked it or tears out i saw
you about that
yeah yeah you look [__] good yeah
yeah yeah anderson does look good yeah
for for his age she looks spectacular i
agree i agree he's he's kind of leading
the charge yeah tito looked like the
[__] [__] vitor belfort looked like
[__] [__]
um
did he call out jake for 25 million veto
yeah the thing about veto is
he's known as
some of the fastest hands in mma history
and he also holds the record for being
the youngest ufc champion ever
officially i think john jones and him
how old is he now um he's 44 he was 21
when he won the title yeah you can tell
because his fans aren't fast anymore
well i mean vito is known for juicing to
the [__] gills
so yeah he
when people they actually nicknamed the
version of him teotihu vito because of
the testosterone replacement therapy he
basically used and you know michael
bisping obviously a huge uk mma legend
he had his
eye damaged by a head kick from veto
when vito was juiced to [__] um mike
bisping obviously never taken anything
in his life so
there's there's a history there of
bad [__] yeah with veto
um so yeah anyone who does take that
fight i encourage
strict drug testing yeah yeah yeah but i
mean
veto is is a name that's the thing and i
think for you guys it's just getting a
fair fight
but is he competing you know but i don't
want to be a [__]
full-on professional boxer i literally
have no interest in doing that i have i
have an interest in putting on the
biggest shows in the world
and vitor belfort is not that
anderson would would make for an
interesting he's still not that
it's more interesting
but it's still
here's why here's what i have to weigh
ready
how good is the guy and how much what
are they bringing to the table anderson
is very good as a boxer and he doesn't
bring that much to the table
unfortunately you're right because
despite anderson being one of the greats
uh he's never had the pay-per-views of a
brock lesnar or a conor mcgregor or you
know so yeah it's risk reward it's a
[__] business i have no i have no oh
man like bro would i fight anderson
silly yes do i think i could beat him
yes am i going to probably not yeah it's
what chill sonnen always says is get the
easiest guy for the biggest check
bingo come on smarter smarter not harder
baby why the [__] would i like come on
yeah i hear that the thing about
anderson that would be cool and i think
you could do this
is some sort of um training video with
him would be sick
saying like you're the first famous guy
i have a yeah
yeah well
that's also that could be cool
that's why also fighting it would be fun
like for that reason alone i kind of
want to i kind of want to fight yeah by
the way it might happen it might
by the way it probably [__] will
unless i have some like change of heart
yeah um and not next though
right so you've got your next yeah yeah
okay yeah i got someone else in mind any
any time frame in mind
nah i don't know i don't know i'm on
some other [__] right now
wait and see what happens with this
you're killing the crypto world right
now yeah here it is end of round seven
and you're looking very fresh
very confident
throwing that jab out floyd is on the
edge of it he's not he's not closing you
down the way he was he's clearly
accepted he's not going to finish you
the the level of risk floyd's taken has
gone down as well yeah
i threw way too many looping punches
dude
taught the time though when you've got
big long arms like you as well as a
short guy
those straight punches probably a lot
easier yeah and also i i throw them
because when i would i'd kind of just
fall onto him and then and it just it's
wasted energy yeah yeah it works either
way i suppose you could see under that
round floyd is
content to just go the distance now he
knows he can't get you out with yeah and
i was surprised by that too dude the
smile on his face is not there now
interesting yeah he goes work the jar he
goes it's hard to hit him with a jam
he's just he's not the same guy he was
at the start of that fight yeah and he
and he admitted that before the fight
started you know that and that was the
whole stick let's see what let's see
what a goat looks like when they're no
longer in their prime yep against the
guy who's like an athlete and just
picked up a new sport this is where my
length like
like especially now in this eighth round
and my confidence was going up
and i realized i was like yo i'm not
only am i gonna finish this [__]
fight out right now but like
this guy's getting tired and and i'm i'm
literally like warming up no you
actually you can see that you've got
some good spring in your step there
you're getting a second wind
you're looking fine i had no worry about
you yeah i was not like oh my god it's a
final round yeah you know
the deeper these fights go for me the
better and i i might actually do 10 12
run fights from now on that would that
would benefit you though because how
many people are as athletic as you yeah
even pro fighters
a lot of them are tough guys don't get
me wrong but you you you are gifted jake
and i are always very honest with each
other about our ability and he's always
like my conditioning has always been
it's never been the the thing besides
that first well that wasn't even that
wasn't the conditioning thing i think
that was more the occasion
yeah looking at you in the second fight
and now this fight you clearly don't
have stamina problems yeah but anyone
has wobbly legs and nerves going through
them earlier if the fact that this is
your third fight
and you were able to show this level of
composure even this
you know like i was saying about my
boxing coach he was like i'm not you
know i've had a hundred how much i
fights ten pro fights and even i would
be nervous as [__] for a an event like
this yeah yeah i don't think people
unless you're a boxer yourself a lot of
people are never going to give you the
credit for that because they just don't
get what the [__] you're going through
here and i have no problem with that
yeah that's what their fault is they
don't know yep yeah to be the whole
[__] show at your stage of your
career it's quite something yeah
it's a dream come true to be honest bro
like all of this is just so surreal yep
landing the job
floyd just on the end of it not
committing not really taking any chances
that's how i bro it's this is the eighth
round this is where he should be given
life 100
bro
you're feeling it now 100 percent
this is i was i was literally about to
enter flow state yeah
yeah i do think a few more rounds would
have been good for you for sure
i go you see that
that's your legacy goodbye
what's he saying can you remember
trying to read his lips
hey well done bro let's go you did well
i hope you're proud of that yeah mission
accomplished yeah of course i'm proud
i'm proud of of of
doing it
and getting it done
more than my performance
but but you know still
not getting knocked out
is a win when i watch this back i don't
know what was going through your head
like emotionally how how were you
feeling at the full
at the end of the bend of the round
perplexed
honestly perplexed and and
and confused because like why me dude
like i'm getting goose once again like
what
test my skills
just to have some fun
great young fighter
strong tough tough
you know he said that through gritted
teeth
expectations but he wanted to say i'm
the best i told you i'm the best
there's there's no humility in floyd
mayweather anyone believes that you
ain't been watching long enough
[__] off
this is what surprised me is is
immediately here
your emotions
i don't know but like you look almost a
little drained because you've maybe gone
through so much like you're almost like
not sure what to feel
bingo
yeah
it's hard to put into words dude i've
been through so much [__]
like
at one point legitimately legitimately
was the most hated person
on the planet i can remember
and to go from like that space
to this
like on paper that's impossible on paper
that's [__] impossible
to just become the most hated person on
the planet is impossible i did it not
i'm not proud of it but i accidentally
[__] i [__] did it whatever it was
like i accept it it happened yeah and
then to do this
again on paper is impossible and i i was
i managed to do both and it like the the
journey was insane and afterwards it's
all so hard to download
that i kind of just shut down and yeah
it's a lot for one person to process
that you know even to be in the position
to become that hated is strangely hard
to do but then to recover from that is
even harder and you did all of that
because because in a short time to
recover from that took a major character
development and a commitment to
bettering myself
[Music]
that
was hard it's [__] hard to change who
you are
i had to i was
a butthole of a human
you know
and
and i was i was i was proud of the fight
but i guess it was more just like
i did have to pat myself in the back and
take a second to just be proud of what
what just happened
you should bro honestly
chicks
giving you those words have any steam no
you didn't give a [__] maybe one or two
body shots bro but it's full mayweather
i'm proud of you
[Laughter]
i'm proud
[Music]
everyone all of his close friends
around them with all their watches on
thanks floyd
don't worry
let anyone hit you on the street but
look after you just keep giving us those
rolexes i really don't think this i mean
it didn't i don't think it meant
anything to him yeah i didn't bro
there's another fight he doesn't give a
[__] for me it was everything you know
yeah it's cool this will set me up for
the rest of my life 100
this is part of the in the book this is
the chapter 100
turning point yeah what just happened
um
by far
the most significant special moment of
my life
[Music]
this fight was not just about me
everyone in this room knows you can't do
it without a team i have the best team
in the world
if you contributed to my life in any way
thank you this moment is so special to
me
i don't know where i'm gonna go from
here
but i know it's gonna be way up and i
couldn't have done it without y'all so
thank you
it's a lot it's a lot more it's a lot
and you know what it is when i first
interviewed you
you know you talk about change yeah that
i i literally interviewed when you're in
the eye of the storm obviously the
original interview we did you could
never have spoken like that then you
could you would never have been able to
open up and just let it all come out and
just say yes i'm feeling yep
i got humbled then i took up boxing that
changed my life and then the podcast as
well like just getting to talk to so
many people from so many different walks
of life and truly like be just a student
of experience
and and and and leading with gratitude
and acknowledging those around you who
helped you achieve your success you're
not saying how great am i you're saying
thank you for making me it's not bro i
am a vessel of of my goals and
the people around me yeah you're the
vehicle but yeah there's a lot going
into it uh that was a great chat i
thoroughly enjoyed this hell yeah bro
that's that's crazy this is the pain
game podcast don't forget to subscribe
for more it's on itunes it's on all of
all of them you know spotify and that
and hopefully i will be interviewing
logan ahead of his next huge fight no
doubt that'll take over the world
yes it will uh what he says
and uh we'll have it back on again bro
cool appreciate you jordy peace thanks a
lot